i'm curious because i'm a huge advocate
for term limits in congress and you've
seen with some senators such as pat
toomey that they're able to legislate
much differently knowing that they're
leaving
they take risks that otherwise they
wouldn't take if they were up for
re-election so what what would you
change about term structure term limits
at the fed i'm i'm curious this is my
world
uh it is my world as well so i let me
say i have given it a lot of thought
and
the what i would like is for the fed
chairman
who is presently named for four years
and it happens midway through the
presidential term so it doesn't end with
the presidential presidential election
but it ends about 15 months
16 months later
i would like that pattern to continue to
provide an element of
separation between the president of the
country and the chairman of the federal
reserve
but the point i really would like to see
is for the fed chairman to be nominated
for a single six-year term you are not
re-electable
and the reason is today we have all the
speculation about what will happen in
the fed
and powell will be nominated or not
nominated starting february 1st 2022
and i had thought that president biden
might announce it by jackson hole but
that's not happening now it's expected
september october
and we see the news report saying
treasury secretary yellen is all in
favor of his renomination so for all
practical purposes it looks like he will
be renominated
what's the problem here he has to be
thinking about that in terms of when to
uh should stop when to start tapering
and to start that's right increase
interest rates if i would fit chairman
put me in that spot and i would say
i'll take care of it after i'm
renominated exactly let me get past
february the 1st where is fed
independence
absolutely nowhere so
friend independence is a fiction and the
only way you're going to get out of it
is if you nominate me for six years and
after six years i have to quit and if
that had been done with jerome powell he
has another two more years to go goes
into 2024
and then he knows that he has to be
worried about his legacy how he
performed in six years
and then you would be talking about a
successor if you're thinking about lael
brainerd as a successor for instance she
would start also for another six year
term
or anybody else for that matter sure
so that i think is a major issue the
second issue i have with the fed
is studying federal reserve history
the last time a federal reserve chairman
was outvoted
was in 1986 the early part of the year
paul walker my hero in bringing down
inflation
found out
that he was outvoted and preston martin
the vice chairman
and reagan nominee had voted against him
although by the end of that day he had
pulled his boat back but
first time around volker was outwarded
there was the mutiny in the echo mutiny
in the fed and there was a lot of talk
doesn't mean paul volcker should resign
i'm not saying he should have resigned
at all
the view then was
president reagan did a few things in
iran contra nicaragua marines get killed
very sad for all of us but
that doesn't mean that president reagan
should resign he did not resign
in this case i don't think chairman
volcker should have resigned because of
that
but it is good to have the dissent and
have that come out in public oh
absolutely why am i as a taxpayer paying
for 12 voting members but i'm really
getting one person why don't the other
12 11 person why do i need them so
that's the second issue i have with the
way in which the fed is being run
[Music]
you